[Musique]
le premier médicament qui ralentirait la
progression de la terrible maladie
d'alzheimer vient d'être approuvé aux
états unis a dû elle un anticorps
monoclonal développé par la compagnie
biogen
c'est une excellente nouvelle ça fait
quand même plus de quinze ans qu'on
attendait une nouvelle comme celle ci ce
médicament permet de combattre la
formation de plaques amyloïdes sur les
neurones cerveau des gens atteints
d'alzheimer
un phénomène qui croient ton
provoquerait de la démence chez ceux qui
en sont victimes a dû elle ne serait
efficace qu'au stade précoce de la
maladie
il doit être pris en continu par
intraveineuse
ça a permis en fait une diminution de la
présence des plaques de bêta amyloïde
dans le cerveau une amélioration des
fonctions cognitives et des fonctions
exécutives et même aussi jusqu'à un
certain niveau une amélioration de ce
qu'on appelle le fardeau des proches
aidants
il faut cependant rappeler qu
l'approbation de ce produit s'est faite
dans la contreverse en 2019
après des premiers résultats qui n'est
décevant biogen avait abandonné ce
traitement puis elle redémarre une
nouvelle étude qui a été critiquée par
les experts avant d'obtenir finalement
une autorisation de mise en marché
on a réalisé les années d'une certaine
façon finalement de vie quelque chose de
positif
mais l'effet sur la mémoire
il est très mauvaise par contre l'agencé
mehr kahn a imposé certaines balises à
la compagnie acceptez-le médicaments
conditionnellement à une troisième étude
qui elle devra clairement montré
l'efficacité et le bénéfice pour le
patient
la maladie d'alzheimer représente de 60
à 80 % des cas de démence diagnostic et
demi million de canadiens souffrent et
plus de 150000 québécois
le coût du traitement est estimé à
quelques dizaines de milliers de dollars
par année
une facture qui pourrait être salée pour
les systèmes de santé qui accepteront de
le rembourser
ça vaut la peine surtout pour les
personnes qui actuellement reçoivent un
diagnostic et qui pour eux bay a aucun
espoir étant donné que pour le moment la
maladie d'alzheimer est une maladie
incurable
biogen n'ai pas encore fait de demande
d'autorisation de son médicament au
canada
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal